This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。人类出品，品质保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《硬核吸取教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全去坦诚交流的对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界传递出一个信号：你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你非得这么做，听听并吸取教训吧。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.|||在 AHA 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《硬核吸取教训》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个男人也遭遇了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河的陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即英文数字 TWO 的那个百分之二，在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, I am absolutely buzzing to dive into a topic that I think has seemingly exploded our own.
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, I am absolutely buzzing to dive into a topic that I think has seemingly exploded our own.|||相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们》。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化与过渡，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析二十岁的心理学。今天，我感到无比兴奋，想要深入探讨一个话题，这个话题似乎在我们的。
of nowhere, yet when you really like take some time to look into it has kind of always been part of humanity in like one form or another. We're talking about trinket culture. And you might be raising your eyebrows thinking, trinkets, like you're going to do a whole entire episode on tiny little decorative objects. And I get it. Not everyone will like them, not everyone collects them. That's totally fine. But they are undeniably a really big deal at the moment. big part of the current culture. I'm sure you've seen these unboxing videos or adorable figurines and lububoos. Maybe you've even got a little special shelf at home meticulously dedicated to a collection of utterly non-functional items that just simply make you smile. You know, love them or hate them.
of nowhere, yet when you really like take some time to look into it has kind of always been part of humanity in like one form or another. We're talking about trinket culture. And you might be raising your eyebrows thinking, trinkets, like you're going to do a whole entire episode on tiny little decorative objects. And I get it. Not everyone will like them, not everyone collects them. That's totally fine. But they are undeniably a really big deal at the moment. big part of the current culture. I'm sure you've seen these unboxing videos or adorable figurines and lububoos. Maybe you've even got a little special shelf at home meticulously dedicated to a collection of utterly non-functional items that just simply make you smile. You know, love them or hate them.|||毫无征兆地突然爆发，然而当你真正花时间去研究时，会发现它其实一直以某种形式存在于人类历史中。我们要谈论的是小饰品文化（trinket culture）。你可能会扬起眉毛想：小饰品？居然要为微小的装饰品做一个整整一期的节目。我懂的。不是每个人都喜欢它们，也不是每个人都收藏它们。这完全没问题。但它们不可否认地是当下非常热门的大事件。是当前文化的重要组成部分。我确信你一定看过那些开箱视频，或者可爱的玩偶和拉布布（lububoos）。也许你家里甚至还有一个专门的小架子，一丝不苟地摆放着完全没有实际功能、却能让你会心一笑的收藏品。你知道的，无论你爱它们还是恨它们。
It is highly likely that you have been exposed to some kind of trinket doing the rounds online or in real life. It is a widespread, almost cult-like obsession that we're seeing these days, the psychology of which is so fascinating and only just beginning to be talked about. And I have to admit, I myself, am a trinket collector. If you follow me on Instagram, you will know that not only do I have a stupid amount of sunny angels, like 400 and counting at this point, but I also have like a huge collection of mugs and toys and decorative things that I've picked up from the time I was a child, like displayed all throughout my house. You know, when I was a kid, I collected beanie babies. Then it was kinder egg toys. Now it's key chains and sunny angels, whatever it is. And so,
It is highly likely that you have been exposed to some kind of trinket doing the rounds online or in real life. It is a widespread, almost cult-like obsession that we're seeing these days, the psychology of which is so fascinating and only just beginning to be talked about. And I have to admit, I myself, am a trinket collector. If you follow me on Instagram, you will know that not only do I have a stupid amount of sunny angels, like 400 and counting at this point, but I also have like a huge collection of mugs and toys and decorative things that I've picked up from the time I was a child, like displayed all throughout my house. You know, when I was a kid, I collected beanie babies. Then it was kinder egg toys. Now it's key chains and sunny angels, whatever it is. And so,|||你很有可能已经在网络或现实生活中接触过某种流行的小饰品。这是我们如今看到的一种广泛存在、近乎狂热的痴迷现象，其背后的心理机制如此迷人，并且才刚刚开始被人讨论。我必须承认，我自己就是一个小饰品收藏者。如果你在 Instagram 上关注了我，你就会知道，我不仅拥有数量惊人的 Sonny Angel 盲盒公仔，目前已经有 400 个之多还在增加，而且我还收藏了海量的马克杯、玩具和从小到大收集的各种装饰品，它们摆放了我房子的各个角落。你知道的，当我还是个孩子的时候，我收集豆豆娃娃（beanie babies）。后来是健达奇趣蛋玩具。现在则是钥匙扣和 Sonny Angel，不管是什么。所以，|||
as a member of the Trinket Collector Society, I am really fascinated by what it is about these things that attract us to them. Is there a certain kind of personality that is more drawn to it than another? where and what does our kind of collective infatuation with lububoos and Miffy and sunny angels and jellycats really say about us as a society and even even about the kind of economic times that we're living in so that is precisely what we are going to unravel today the psychology of trinket culture this topic is so much more than a passing fad as we get further into it you're going to you're going to be shocked at how much this, you know, kind of obscure topic really has to say about our minds as humans, about our economy, about our identity, about how we relate to other people.
as a member of the Trinket Collector Society, I am really fascinated by what it is about these things that attract us to them. Is there a certain kind of personality that is more drawn to it than another? where and what does our kind of collective infatuation with lububoos and Miffy and sunny angels and jellycats really say about us as a society and even even about the kind of economic times that we're living in so that is precisely what we are going to unravel today the psychology of trinket culture this topic is so much more than a passing fad as we get further into it you're going to you're going to be shocked at how much this, you know, kind of obscure topic really has to say about our minds as humans, about our economy, about our identity, about how we relate to other people.|||作为“小饰品收藏者协会”的一员，我真的非常着迷于这些东西究竟有什么魔力在吸引着我们。是否某种特定性格的人比其他人更容易被它们吸引？以及我们对拉布布、米菲兔、Sonny Angel 和 Jellycat 的这种集体痴迷，究竟说明了我们是一个什么样的社会，甚至说明了我们正生活在什么样的经济时代？这正是我们今天要剖析的内容——小饰品文化的心理学。这个话题远不止是一时的潮流，随着我们深入探讨，你会感到震惊，这个看似冷门的话题竟然对我们的人类心理、我们的经济、我们的身份认同以及我们与他人的关系有着如此多的启示。
Like, who knew you could go so deep when talking about key chains and fluffy animals and tiny baby dolls? But turns out it is a lot deeper than you may initially imagine. So my lovely listeners, strap in for a kind of wacky, kind of different conversation, but one that is like chock-full with science, surprisingly. Let's talk about the psychology of trinket culture. Stay with us. So let's start with the biggest question to begin with. Where the heck has this all come from? How did something as seemingly niche as collecting small figures go from a hobby for just a select few, something people even thought of as kind of weird to literally being everywhere, to being part of a celebrity culture, to being part of the literal economy.
Like, who knew you could go so deep when talking about key chains and fluffy animals and tiny baby dolls? But turns out it is a lot deeper than you may initially imagine. So my lovely listeners, strap in for a kind of wacky, kind of different conversation, but one that is like chock-full with science, surprisingly. Let's talk about the psychology of trinket culture. Stay with us. So let's start with the biggest question to begin with. Where the heck has this all come from? How did something as seemingly niche as collecting small figures go from a hobby for just a select few, something people even thought of as kind of weird to literally being everywhere, to being part of a celebrity culture, to being part of the literal economy.|||谁能想到，在谈论钥匙扣、毛绒动物和微型娃娃时，竟然能探讨得如此深奥？但事实证明，它比你最初想象的要深得多。所以，我可爱的听众们，系好安全带，准备迎接一场有点古怪、有点与众不同的对话，但令人惊奇的是，这场对话充满了科学。让我们来谈谈小饰品文化的心理学。请继续收听。那么，我们先从最大的问题开始。这一切究竟是从哪里来的？像收集小玩偶这样看似小众的爱好，是如何从少数人的小众爱好（甚至被人们认为有点怪异）演变成无处不在、成为名流文化的一部分、乃至成为真实经济的一部分的？
Maybe, unsurprisingly, a huge part of it recently and probably the main driver lies squarely with our digital landscape, especially platforms like TikTok, Instagram, Pinterest. These platforms are perfect for short-lived aesthetic trends like ballet core. tomato girl, summer, cottage core. We've seen them come up and down for years. Ever since like TikTok and Instagram really hit their like high point, trends have been a part of that. And things like Trinket Hall videos or unboxing experiences or trinket shelf tours that are racking up millions of views, it is in some ways just another trend. And this kind of content is also really engaging. It creates a lot of desirability.
Maybe, unsurprisingly, a huge part of it recently and probably the main driver lies squarely with our digital landscape, especially platforms like TikTok, Instagram, Pinterest. These platforms are perfect for short-lived aesthetic trends like ballet core. tomato girl, summer, cottage core. We've seen them come up and down for years. Ever since like TikTok and Instagram really hit their like high point, trends have been a part of that. And things like Trinket Hall videos or unboxing experiences or trinket shelf tours that are racking up millions of views, it is in some ways just another trend. And this kind of content is also really engaging. It creates a lot of desirability.|||也许并不令人意外的是，最近这其中的很大一部分原因，以及主要的推动力，直接在于我们的数字环境，尤其是像 TikTok、Instagram、Pinterest 这样的平台。这些平台非常适合昙花一现的美学潮流，比如芭蕾风（ballet core）、番茄女孩夏日（tomato girl summer）、田园风（cottage core）。多年来，我们看着它们兴起又衰落。自从 TikTok 和 Instagram 真正达到高潮以来，潮流就一直是其中的一部分。像小饰品战利品分享（Trinket Haul）视频、开箱体验或小饰品书架参观等获得了数百万次观看的内容，在某种程度上也只是又一种潮流。而且这类内容也非常引人入胜。它创造了极大的渴望。
There's a lot of buzz around it. There's a much deeper part to our culture that has become quite obsessive with this level of consumption and also like displays of just like excess, like someone having all of these things and being able to watch them and like live this like cool life through their eyes is really, really appealing. You see it, you want it. And before you know it, you're not just a passive observer. like you are part of the movement, you are part of the business model. Take Pop Mart, for instance,
There's a lot of buzz around it. There's a much deeper part to our culture that has become quite obsessive with this level of consumption and also like displays of just like excess, like someone having all of these things and being able to watch them and like live this like cool life through their eyes is really, really appealing. You see it, you want it. And before you know it, you're not just a passive observer. like you are part of the movement, you are part of the business model. Take Pop Mart, for instance,|||围绕它有很多讨论。我们的文化中有一个更深层的部分，变得对这种消费水平以及对纯粹过剩事物的展示相当痴迷，比如某人拥有所有这些东西，能够通过他们的眼睛去观看并过上这种酷炫的生活，这真的非常有吸引力。你看到了，你就会想要。不知不觉中，你不再只是一个旁观者。就像你是这场运动的一部分，你是商业模式的一部分。以泡泡玛特（Pop Mart）为例，
Pop Mart has been everywhere. They are the powerhouse behind Lubbubu figures, I guess the Lubu toys. The reason they became so successful is because they marketed themselves so well, especially through social media and especially through their packaging, especially through their entire business model of blind boxes, not knowing what you're going to get. Hot Mart shops are like consistently selling out in London, in America, in Australia, literally anywhere you can name a city and a country, you will find a Lubbubu. And this isn't just a toy for children. It's a legitimate like cultural touchstone.
Pop Mart has been everywhere. They are the powerhouse behind Lubbubu figures, I guess the Lubu toys. The reason they became so successful is because they marketed themselves so well, especially through social media and especially through their packaging, especially through their entire business model of blind boxes, not knowing what you're going to get. Hot Mart shops are like consistently selling out in London, in America, in Australia, literally anywhere you can name a city and a country, you will find a Lubbubu. And this isn't just a toy for children. It's a legitimate like cultural touchstone.|||泡泡玛特无处不在。它们是拉布布玩偶（我猜是指 Labubu 玩具）背后的强大推手。他们之所以如此成功，是因为他们的营销做得太出色了，特别是在社交媒体上，特别是在包装方面，尤其是通过盲盒这一整套商业模式——你永远不知道自己会买到什么。泡泡玛特的门店在伦敦、美国、澳大利亚都持续售罄，简直在你能说出名字的任何城市和国家，你都能找到拉布布的身影。这不仅仅是给小孩子玩的玩具。它是一个名正言顺的文化标杆。
There's even Labibu key chains, you know, at London Fashion Week. Some of these things sell for like thousands of dollars. It's like a craze has taken over and something that was meant to be cute has turned into kind of like a status symbol in a way. you know, individually these items are kind of seemingly like semi-affordable niceties. They're like a special treat if you buy one. You know, a sunny angel figurine, for example, in Australia that's going to cost you like maybe $17 to $20.
There's even Labibu key chains, you know, at London Fashion Week. Some of these things sell for like thousands of dollars. It's like a craze has taken over and something that was meant to be cute has turned into kind of like a status symbol in a way. you know, individually these items are kind of seemingly like semi-affordable niceties. They're like a special treat if you buy one. You know, a sunny angel figurine, for example, in Australia that's going to cost you like maybe $17 to $20.|||甚至连伦敦时装周上都能看到 Labubu 钥匙扣。其中一些东西能卖到几千美元。这就像是一场狂热席卷了这一切，原本应该是可爱的小物件，在某种程度上却变成了身份的象征。你知道的，单看这些物品，它们似乎是那种半负担得起的小奢侈品。如果你买一个，就像是给自己的一份特别奖励。你知道的，以一个 Sonny Angel 玩偶为例，在澳大利亚，买一个大概要花 17 到 20 美元。
That's, you know, a lot of money, but also not a lot of money. Like that's how much you would spend on a nice, like on lunch. You know what I mean? But here's the kick up. They're a small purchase, but they accumulate fast. especially when you're on a quest to complete a full set or, you know, there's this latest drop that you just have to have, or there's a rare item that you want to keep buying boxes in order to get. Behind the cuteness of this all is a business model that is capitalizing on our desire
That's, you know, a lot of money, but also not a lot of money. Like that's how much you would spend on a nice, like on lunch. You know what I mean? But here's the kick up. They're a small purchase, but they accumulate fast. especially when you're on a quest to complete a full set or, you know, there's this latest drop that you just have to have, or there's a rare item that you want to keep buying boxes in order to get. Behind the cuteness of this all is a business model that is capitalizing on our desire|||这，你知道的，既算是一笔不少的钱，其实也不算太多。这就相当于你在外面吃顿不错午餐的花费。你知道我的意思吗？但关键点在这里。它们虽然是小额消费，但累积起来非常快。尤其是当你执着于凑齐一整套时，或者你知道的，有最新发售的款式你非买不可，又或者为了得到一个稀有款而不断买盲盒。这一切可爱外表背后，是一个正在利用我们欲望的商业模式。
to accumulate more and more and more. Each new release taps into the psychology of scarcity and completionism. There's limited additions. There's mystery. boxes and the thrill of getting the one you secretly wanted all along really plays into your impulse to keep collecting. So it's not just about owning a figurine and it's not just about owning the toy. That's something that I think people sometimes don't understand. It's about the feeling of anticipation. It's about even being able to get your hands on one in the first place. It's the rush of the unboxing and the sense of belonging to a community that kind of gets it. And so the cycle continues. A tiny figurine becomes like this tiny obsession. And the dollar value on that business model is
to accumulate more and more and more. Each new release taps into the psychology of scarcity and completionism. There's limited additions. There's mystery. boxes and the thrill of getting the one you secretly wanted all along really plays into your impulse to keep collecting. So it's not just about owning a figurine and it's not just about owning the toy. That's something that I think people sometimes don't understand. It's about the feeling of anticipation. It's about even being able to get your hands on one in the first place. It's the rush of the unboxing and the sense of belonging to a community that kind of gets it. And so the cycle continues. A tiny figurine becomes like this tiny obsession. And the dollar value on that business model is|||即渴望积累更多、更多、更多。每一次新品发售都契合了稀缺心理和收集癖。有限量版。有神秘盲盒。而抽中心里一直暗暗想要的那一款的兴奋感，极大地诱发了你持续收集的冲动.所以这不仅仅是拥有一个玩偶，也不仅仅是拥有一个玩具。这是我认为人们有时不理解的地方。这关乎期待的感觉。甚至关乎你能否首先把它弄到手。那是开箱时的快感，以及对一个“懂这种感觉”的社群的归属感。于是循环往复。一个小小的玩偶变成了这样一种微小的痴迷。而那种商业模式背后的美元价值是
insane. Like it is a highly lucrative industry. Let's focus back in on Pop Mart again. Their company valuation has completely skyrocketed. In 2024, their like valuation, how much they were worth, how much money they made was 60.45 billion. dollars, B, billion, not M, billion, like billion. Let's just think about that for a moment. Like, that is actually more than, and I looked this up, more than the combined valuations of Mattel, so literally the creator of Barbie Hot Wheels, it's more than that combined with the creators of Nerf Gun, My Little Pony, Transformers, Hello Kitty, you could add up
insane. Like it is a highly lucrative industry. Let's focus back in on Pop Mart again. Their company valuation has completely skyrocketed. In 2024, their like valuation, how much they were worth, how much money they made was 60.45 billion. dollars, B, billion, not M, billion, like billion. Let's just think about that for a moment. Like, that is actually more than, and I looked this up, more than the combined valuations of Mattel, so literally the creator of Barbie Hot Wheels, it's more than that combined with the creators of Nerf Gun, My Little Pony, Transformers, Hello Kitty, you could add up|||疯狂的。就像这是一个暴利行业。让我们把目光重新聚焦回泡泡玛特。他们的公司估值彻底暴涨了。在2024年，他们的估值——他们值多少钱，他们赚了多少钱——是604.5亿。美元，是 B 代表的十亿（billion），不是 M 代表的百万（million），是十亿级别。让我们花点时间想一想。这实际上比——我查过这个——比美泰（Mattel，也就是芭比娃娃和风火轮的创造者）的总估值还要高，甚至比它加上 Nerf 软弹枪、小马宝莉、变形金刚、Hello Kitty 的创造者的总估值还要高，你可以把
how much each of those businesses was worth. And all added up, it would not even scratch the surface of how much pot mark is worth. That says everything about how seriously this little niche thing is being taken. So other than the fact, as we previously mentioned, why do we fall so hard for trinkets beyond just wanting more things, beyond just consumerism? Firstly, I think in a world of traditional luxury goods, you know, design handbags, high-end cars, exotic vacations, a lot of those things. A lot of those things remain largely out of reach for us, but trinkets have emerged as these like surprisingly potent and incredibly affordable status symbols. They offer a very clever way for us to signal our identity and our taste and our kind of in the no status without having to totally
how much each of those businesses was worth. And all added up, it would not even scratch the surface of how much pot mark is worth. That says everything about how seriously this little niche thing is being taken. So other than the fact, as we previously mentioned, why do we fall so hard for trinkets beyond just wanting more things, beyond just consumerism? Firstly, I think in a world of traditional luxury goods, you know, design handbags, high-end cars, exotic vacations, a lot of those things. A lot of those things remain largely out of reach for us, but trinkets have emerged as these like surprisingly potent and incredibly affordable status symbols. They offer a very clever way for us to signal our identity and our taste and our kind of in the no status without having to totally|||每一个这样企业的价值加起来。所有这些加在一起，连泡泡玛特价值的皮毛都比不上。这说明了一切，说明这个小众的小玩儿意被多么严重地对待了。那么，除了我们之前提到的事实之外，为什么除了想要更多东西、除了单纯的消费主义之外，我们会对小饰品如此深深着迷？首先，我认为在传统奢侈品的世界里，你知道的，设计师手袋、高端汽车、异国度假，很多这类的东西。许多这类的东西对我们来说仍然遥不可及，但小饰品却作为这种出人意料地强大且极其经济实惠的身份象征脱颖而出。它们为我们提供了一种非常巧妙的方式来标榜我们的身份、品味以及那种“懂行”的地位，而不必完全
break the bank, which is why I think for people in their late teens and in their 20s, there's such a pool. Their primary power kind of lies in their accessibility. Unlike really, really, expensive luxury items, most trinkets are relatively inexpensive. So it makes them accessible to a demographic who definitely wants to show that they have their lives together or that they have their finances together but can't necessarily go after the traditional indicators of wealth. When you see, you know, global style icons like Rihanna and do a leper or Kylie Jenner or even like David Beckham, like sporting a Lubbubu, it just kind of amplifies this perception that this is something that someone who is in the no has.
break the bank, which is why I think for people in their late teens and in their 20s, there's such a pool. Their primary power kind of lies in their accessibility. Unlike really, really, expensive luxury items, most trinkets are relatively inexpensive. So it makes them accessible to a demographic who definitely wants to show that they have their lives together or that they have their finances together but can't necessarily go after the traditional indicators of wealth. When you see, you know, global style icons like Rihanna and do a leper or Kylie Jenner or even like David Beckham, like sporting a Lubbubu, it just kind of amplifies this perception that this is something that someone who is in the no has.|||倾家荡产，这就是为什么我认为对于十几岁末期和二十多岁的年轻人来说，有如此巨大的吸引力。它们的核心力量在于其亲民性。与那些非常非常昂贵的奢侈品不同，大多数小饰品相对便宜。这使得它们能够被这样一个群体所接触到：他们非常想表现出自己把生活打理得井井有条，或者财务状况良好，但不一定能去追求传统的财富指标。当你看到，你知道的，像蕾哈娜（Rihanna）、杜阿·利帕（Dua Lipa）、凯莉·詹娜（Kylie Jenner）甚至像大卫·贝克汉姆（David Beckham）这样的全球时尚偶像，都在背上挂着一个拉布布时，这只会放大这样一种看法：这是内行人才会拥有的东西。
This is something that someone who's cool or who has wealth or status has. And it's the same reason why companies put celebrities as the face of perfumes, cars, drinks, fashion brands, because they know we are more likely to buy something if we see someone we admire doing it first because we think, I can be more like them. You know, I might not be rich or famous, but I can dress or smell like a rich and famous person. I can have the collectible on my bag that a rich and famous person has. You know, humans, we are at our core deeply social creatures. We have this inherent drive to connect and to belong.
This is something that someone who's cool or who has wealth or status has. And it's the same reason why companies put celebrities as the face of perfumes, cars, drinks, fashion brands, because they know we are more likely to buy something if we see someone we admire doing it first because we think, I can be more like them. You know, I might not be rich or famous, but I can dress or smell like a rich and famous person. I can have the collectible on my bag that a rich and famous person has. You know, humans, we are at our core deeply social creatures. We have this inherent drive to connect and to belong.|||这是某个很酷、拥有财富或地位的人所拥有的东西。这也是为什么公司会让名人担任香水、汽车、饮料、时尚品牌的代言人，因为他们知道，如果我们看到自己钦佩的人先去买某个东西，我们就更有可能去买，因为我们会想：我可以变得更像他们。你知道的，我可能既不富有也不出名，但我可以穿得像个富有且出名的人，或者有他们身上那种气味。我可以在我的包上挂一个富豪名流都有的收藏品。你知道的，人类，我们的核心是极具社会属性的生物。我们有着连接和归属的内在驱动力。
And these trinkets are incredibly powerful at fostering a sense of in-group belonging and really solidifying our social identity and what we want to communicate to the world. They tap directly into our fundamental need for connection and acceptance. And if you think that that sounds crazy, let me explain a little bit of the psychology behind this. When you start collecting specific types of trinkets, not only does it seemingly align you with other people who see value in that item, maybe like a celebrity, it also almost automatically leads to the formation of communities, both online and in real life. There are entire Facebook groups for people who collect, you know, rare littlerless pet shops.
And these trinkets are incredibly powerful at fostering a sense of in-group belonging and really solidifying our social identity and what we want to communicate to the world. They tap directly into our fundamental need for connection and acceptance. And if you think that that sounds crazy, let me explain a little bit of the psychology behind this. When you start collecting specific types of trinkets, not only does it seemingly align you with other people who see value in that item, maybe like a celebrity, it also almost automatically leads to the formation of communities, both online and in real life. There are entire Facebook groups for people who collect, you know, rare littlerless pet shops.|||而这些小饰品在培养内群体归属感、巩固我们的社会认同感以及我们想要向世界传达的信息方面，具有极其强大的力量。它们直接触及了我们对连接和接纳的根本需求。如果你觉得这听起来很疯狂，让我来解释一下这背后的部分心理学原理。当你开始收集特定类型的小饰品时，它不仅似乎让你与那些看到该物品价值的人（也许像某个名人）保持一致，而且几乎会自动导致线上和现实生活中社群的形成。存在着专门针对那些收集稀有“小小宠物店（Littlest Pet Shop）”玩具的人的整个 Facebook 群组。
the same way that there are entire Facebook groups for people who collect stamps or car parts. And in those groups, you will find people with the same interests, the same knowledge set, the same obsession as you. And that's kind of really fun to lean into. So according to social identity theory, we really derive a lot of our self-esteem from group membership. And you don't have to actively participate in a group like a Facebook group to still feel like you belong somewhere. Collecting and displaying trick. It reinforces a connection that you have with a certain type of person, whether it's a sunny angel, whether it's whatever it is. By actively like participating in trinket culture, you're basically
the same way that there are entire Facebook groups for people who collect stamps or car parts. And in those groups, you will find people with the same interests, the same knowledge set, the same obsession as you. And that's kind of really fun to lean into. So according to social identity theory, we really derive a lot of our self-esteem from group membership. And you don't have to actively participate in a group like a Facebook group to still feel like you belong somewhere. Collecting and displaying trick. It reinforces a connection that you have with a certain type of person, whether it's a sunny angel, whether it's whatever it is. By actively like participating in trinket culture, you're basically|||就像有专门为集邮者或汽车零件收集者开设的整个 Facebook 群组一样。在这些群组中，你会发现有着与你相同兴趣、相同知识储备、相同痴迷程度的人。深入其中真的会很有趣。因此，根据社会认同理论，我们的自尊很大程度上来自于群体的成员身份。你不需要积极参与像 Facebook 群组这样的群体，也能感觉到自己属于某个地方。收集和展示小饰品。它强化了你与特定类型的人之间的联系，无论是 Sonny Angel，还是其他什么东西。通过积极参与小饰品文化，你基本上是在
saying, I'm part of this group. I'm part of this group who spends money on this thing, who uses this as a status symbol, but also maybe part of a group of people who have a lot of whimsy and who really value like childlike wonder and who are really creative, you know, whatever. it is, what this really fosters is what we call collective efferves. So a shared kind of sense of energy and enthusiasm that is generated by communal participation. Isn't that such a beautiful term as well? Collective effervescence. And it's also something that you can feel. Yes, you're going to go out and buy the trinket yourself, but then you might see someone else with the trinket on their bag and you immediately feel like a pull towards them or you might be in line waiting for
saying, I'm part of this group. I'm part of this group who spends money on this thing, who uses this as a status symbol, but also maybe part of a group of people who have a lot of whimsy and who really value like childlike wonder and who are really creative, you know, whatever. it is, what this really fosters is what we call collective efferves. So a shared kind of sense of energy and enthusiasm that is generated by communal participation. Isn't that such a beautiful term as well? Collective effervescence. And it's also something that you can feel. Yes, you're going to go out and buy the trinket yourself, but then you might see someone else with the trinket on their bag and you immediately feel like a pull towards them or you might be in line waiting for|||说：“我是这个群体的一部分。我是这个在这些东西上花钱、把这当作身份象征的群体的一部分，但也许也是这样一群人的一部分：他们充满奇思妙想，非常珍视像孩童般的好奇心，并且极具创造力，无论如何。”这一切真正培养的是我们所说的“集体欢腾（collective effervescence）”。也就是通过共同参与所产生的共享的能量感和热情。难道这也是一个非常美妙的词吗？集体欢腾。这也是你能切实感受到的一种东西。是的，你会亲自出门去买这个小饰品，但随后你可能会看到别人的包上也挂着这个小饰品，你就会立刻对他们产生一种吸引力，或者你可能会在排队等待
like a rare, I don't know, laboo-boob drop and you're like, oh, I feel like I'm aligned with these people and you can talk to them about it and it's something that you can share with your friends and you can connect with people online about. That feeling is the same feeling that people in a stadium feel when they're rooting for the same team or it's the same buzz that you get at a concert for your favorite artist or at a trade show. Humans have found a way to capture this efferves in so many forms. And trinket culture is just another form of that. Even if people think it's childish, the same human desire that causes us to want to be part of any group or want to be in the no also causes us to sometimes become a collector. Beyond social identity, we also have our self-identity.
like a rare, I don't know, laboo-boob drop and you're like, oh, I feel like I'm aligned with these people and you can talk to them about it and it's something that you can share with your friends and you can connect with people online about. That feeling is the same feeling that people in a stadium feel when they're rooting for the same team or it's the same buzz that you get at a concert for your favorite artist or at a trade show. Humans have found a way to capture this efferves in so many forms. And trinket culture is just another form of that. Even if people think it's childish, the same human desire that causes us to want to be part of any group or want to be in the no also causes us to sometimes become a collector. Beyond social identity, we also have our self-identity.|||比如一个稀有的，我不知道，拉布布新品发售，你会想：哦，我觉得我和这些人是一伙的，你可以和他们谈论这个，这是你可以与朋友分享的事情，也可以与网上的其他人建立联系。这种感觉与体育场里的人们为同一支球队加油时感受到的感觉是一样的，或者与你在你最喜欢的艺术家的演唱会上或在贸易展上获得的兴奋感是一样的。人类已经找到了以多种形式捕捉这种欢腾感的方法。而小饰品文化只是其中的又一种形式。即使人们认为它很幼稚，但正是那种让我们渴望成为任何群体的一部分或渴望成为知情者的相同人类欲望，有时也会让我们成为一个收藏者。除了社会认同，我们还有自我认同。
And trinkets are kind of like a non-verbal form of self-expression. You know, if you have a certain anime figurine on your desk, like that's not just decoration. It tells stories. about your interests. It says something about who you are and what you love and how you see the world. You know, a particular trinket might represent that you are playful or that you love a specific subculture or that there's a specific lifestyle that you feel drawn to achieve. The items we own do become part of what psychologists call our extended self. So basically how we think about ourselves as not just like the voice in our head, but the physical things around us. So yes, our extended self is part, isn't part made up by our relationships. It's made up in part by our
And trinkets are kind of like a non-verbal form of self-expression. You know, if you have a certain anime figurine on your desk, like that's not just decoration. It tells stories. about your interests. It says something about who you are and what you love and how you see the world. You know, a particular trinket might represent that you are playful or that you love a specific subculture or that there's a specific lifestyle that you feel drawn to achieve. The items we own do become part of what psychologists call our extended self. So basically how we think about ourselves as not just like the voice in our head, but the physical things around us. So yes, our extended self is part, isn't part made up by our relationships. It's made up in part by our|||而小饰品有点像是一种非语言形式的自我表达。你知道的，如果你的桌上放着某个动漫手办，那不仅仅是装饰。它讲述着关于你兴趣的故事。它传达了你是谁、你热爱什么以及你如何看世界。你知道的，某个特定的小饰品可能代表着你很有趣，或者你热爱某个特定的亚文化，或者有一种你渴望实现的生活方式。我们拥有的物品确实成为了心理学家所说的“延展自我（extended self）”的一部分。所以基本上，我们如何看待自己，不仅仅是脑海中的声音，还包括我们周围的物质事物。所以是的，我们的延展自我的一部分，难道不是由我们的关系构成的吗？它部分是由我们的
environment. It's made up in part by what we read, what we listen to, and also what we own and how we what we choose to decorate our lives with. This is one of the biggest draws of this all. Like it really is this capacity to indicate to others who you are as a person. But while trinkets are often self-expression, I would say that's what I think they are. I think they're self-expression. They also reveal how identity can really be commodified and how authenticity can be commodified. So we're going to talk about the intersection of frinkets, psychology, and also the big C, capitalism. After this, short break, stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
environment. It's made up in part by what we read, what we listen to, and also what we own and how we what we choose to decorate our lives with. This is one of the biggest draws of this all. Like it really is this capacity to indicate to others who you are as a person. But while trinkets are often self-expression, I would say that's what I think they are. I think they're self-expression. They also reveal how identity can really be commodified and how authenticity can be commodified. So we're going to talk about the intersection of frinkets, psychology, and also the big C, capitalism. After this, short break, stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.|||环境构成的。它部分由我们阅读的、我们倾听的，以及我们拥有的东西和我们选择用什么来装饰生活的方式所构成。这是这一切最大的吸引力之一。就像它确实具备向他人表明你是一个什么样的人的能力一样。但虽然小饰品通常是自我表达——我会说这就是我认为它们的作用，我认为它们是自我表达——它们也揭示了身份认同是如何真正被商品化的，以及真实性是如何被商品化的。所以接下来，我们要讨论小饰品、心理学以及大写字母 C 代表的资本主义之间的交汇点。休息一下，马上回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world,
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world,|||我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，
are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||都是压力导致的。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即英文数字 TWO 的那个百分之二。在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s.|||你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系。嗯，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会在这里挑选事件，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, one of the most important years for black people in American history.|||需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都愿意聊聊快克，但只是想让你们大家知道。我的意思是，马克，说到这里，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿的主线了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在了桌面上。谢谢你帮我把这句话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,|||在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核吸取教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person|||我们过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得做一个好人很重要
while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,|||当你在地球上的时候。你是一个好人吗？因为你害怕。因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地成为一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd|||在我的新播客《硬核吸取教训》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索“Learn the hard way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.|||发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.|||阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I am going to say something bold here as a long-time trinket collector myself. I think the good old days of collecting trinkets that were important to you and only you kind of gone. You know, I've just got to say it.
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I am going to say something bold here as a long-time trinket collector myself. I think the good old days of collecting trinkets that were important to you and only you kind of gone. You know, I've just got to say it.|||随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河的陷阱》播客。所以，作为一个资深的小饰品收藏者，我要在这里说一句大胆的话。我认为那种收集对你、而且只对你重要的小饰品的好日子已经一去不复返了。你知道的，我不得不说出来。
Previously, our homes were filled with things that we had collected over the years, from travel, from birthdays, from adventures, and this entire collection, like, yes, maybe someone else had one or two things. similar to you, but it was very unique. It was a postcard from here. It was a special stone from this beach, a collection of mugs from all over. Each person had a different set of things. Nowadays, instead of like carefully curating objects that reflect who you are, were often sold kind of pre-packaged aesthetic starter kits. And it raises the question with trinkets these days. Are we really expressing ourselves or are we just buying into a market?
Previously, our homes were filled with things that we had collected over the years, from travel, from birthdays, from adventures, and this entire collection, like, yes, maybe someone else had one or two things. similar to you, but it was very unique. It was a postcard from here. It was a special stone from this beach, a collection of mugs from all over. Each person had a different set of things. Nowadays, instead of like carefully curating objects that reflect who you are, were often sold kind of pre-packaged aesthetic starter kits. And it raises the question with trinkets these days. Are we really expressing ourselves or are we just buying into a market?|||以前，我们的家里摆满了多年来收集的东西，来自旅行、生日、冒险，而整个收藏就像是，是的，也许别人也有一两件和你相似的东西，但它是非常独特的。那是来自这里的一表明信片。那是来自这片海滩的一块特殊的石头，或是来自各地的马克杯收藏。每个人都有一套不同的东西。如今，我们不再是精心挑选那些反映你是谁的物品，而是经常被兜售那种预先打包好的美学入门套件。这就引发了一个关于如今的小饰品的问题：我们到底是在表达自己，还是仅仅在为一种市场。
persona. And you know, a bigger question is if everyone has something, how genuine and authentic and how much of a form of self-expression can it really be if everyone is expressing the same thing? Critics of consumer culture might argue that authenticity in this day and age itself has become a marketable commodity. Brands are very quick to leverage the idea that a certain person would own this product and another kind of person would buy this kind of thing. So they really sell you the idea that if you are this particular individual, you should buy this candle, or you should wear this jacket, or this trinket is somehow for you. And it will allow you to be more like yourself. It will allow you to be more not just like yourself, but like the other kind of people who own this kind of thing.
persona. And you know, a bigger question is if everyone has something, how genuine and authentic and how much of a form of self-expression can it really be if everyone is expressing the same thing? Critics of consumer culture might argue that authenticity in this day and age itself has become a marketable commodity. Brands are very quick to leverage the idea that a certain person would own this product and another kind of person would buy this kind of thing. So they really sell you the idea that if you are this particular individual, you should buy this candle, or you should wear this jacket, or this trinket is somehow for you. And it will allow you to be more like yourself. It will allow you to be more not just like yourself, but like the other kind of people who own this kind of thing.|||人设买单？你知道的，一个更大的问题是，如果每个人都有某样东西，那么如果每个人都在表达相同的东西，它能有多真诚、多真实，又能有多少自我表达的形式呢？消费文化的批评者可能会争辩说，如今这个时代的真实性本身已经变成了一种可交易的商品。品牌非常善于利用这样一种理念：某种特定的人会拥有这个产品，而另一种人会买这种东西。所以他们真的向你兜售这样一种理念：如果你是这个特定的人，你就应该买这根蜡烛，或者你应该穿这件夹克，或者这个小饰品不知为何就是为你准备的。它会让你更像你自己。它不仅会让你更像你自己，还会让你更像拥有这类东西的其他那一类人。
In doing so, our identities really get tied up in what we own, what we wear, what we display, and it turns consumption into a form of personal branding. What's even more complex, I think, is how consumer culture kind of disguises these decisions as empowerment. You know, the language of choice and freedom is everywhere when it comes to buying things. Things like treat yourself. You deserve it. express who you are, it masks a system that kind of thrives on needing to buy our identity rather than express it through our character. We are subtly encouraged to seek emotional
In doing so, our identities really get tied up in what we own, what we wear, what we display, and it turns consumption into a form of personal branding. What's even more complex, I think, is how consumer culture kind of disguises these decisions as empowerment. You know, the language of choice and freedom is everywhere when it comes to buying things. Things like treat yourself. You deserve it. express who you are, it masks a system that kind of thrives on needing to buy our identity rather than express it through our character. We are subtly encouraged to seek emotional|||通过这样做，我们的身份认同真的与我们拥有的、我们穿戴的、我们展示的东西绑在了一起，它将消费变成了一种个人品牌塑造的形式。我认为更复杂的是消费文化如何把这些决定伪装成一种赋权。你知道的，在购买东西时，关于选择和自由的语言无处不在。诸如“犒劳一下自己”、“你值得拥有”、“表达真实的自我”之类的话，掩盖了一个靠“需要购买我们的身份认同，而不是通过我们的性格来表达它”而蓬勃发展的系统。我们被潜移默化地鼓励去在
fulfillment in material things, only to kind of find out eventually that that satisfaction is very fleeting and we need to fill that hole with something else the next day, the next day, the next week. So a new drop, a fresh aesthetic, it will quickly replace the last thing, keeping us in this constant loop of yearning and also crucially of spending. It's not that consumption is inherently bad, but when it's framed as a way to, I guess, have meaning in life or as a way to express your identity, it becomes a very hollow solution to a much deeper need for connection and purpose and belonging. And I know I'm sounding rather pessimistic. I do also believe that there's some
fulfillment in material things, only to kind of find out eventually that that satisfaction is very fleeting and we need to fill that hole with something else the next day, the next day, the next week. So a new drop, a fresh aesthetic, it will quickly replace the last thing, keeping us in this constant loop of yearning and also crucially of spending. It's not that consumption is inherently bad, but when it's framed as a way to, I guess, have meaning in life or as a way to express your identity, it becomes a very hollow solution to a much deeper need for connection and purpose and belonging. And I know I'm sounding rather pessimistic. I do also believe that there's some|||物质事物中寻求情感上的满足，结果却最终发现这种满足感非常短暂，我们需要在第二天、接下来的每一天、下周用别的东西来填补这个空洞。因此，新品的发售、崭新的美学，会迅速取代上一件东西，让我们陷入这种持续的渴望循环中，而至关重要的是，还有消费的循环。倒不是说消费本身本质上是坏事，但当它被包装成一种寻找生活意义的方式，或者作为一种表达你身份的方式时，它就成了对更深层次的连接、目标和归属感需求的一种非常空洞的解决方案。我知道我听起来相当悲观。我也相信其中确实存在一些
something majorly joyful and special to this habit, other than just like what some people would call naive consumer behavior. And one way that I think it is really, I don't know if beneficial is the right word, but like really joyful and, I don't know, unthreatening is that collecting these little objects can be a real beautiful way to connect with hearts of you that you've kind of hidden, specifically, you know, expressions of our inner child. It's a way to feel young and childlike again. In our very stressful adult lives, consciously reconnecting with the parts of you that feel innocent and soft and playful, you know, that can be incredibly, like it can be an incredibly powerful act of self-care and even of emotional regulation, letting yourself feel safe
something majorly joyful and special to this habit, other than just like what some people would call naive consumer behavior. And one way that I think it is really, I don't know if beneficial is the right word, but like really joyful and, I don't know, unthreatening is that collecting these little objects can be a real beautiful way to connect with hearts of you that you've kind of hidden, specifically, you know, expressions of our inner child. It's a way to feel young and childlike again. In our very stressful adult lives, consciously reconnecting with the parts of you that feel innocent and soft and playful, you know, that can be incredibly, like it can be an incredibly powerful act of self-care and even of emotional regulation, letting yourself feel safe|||重大而快乐、特殊的地方，而不仅仅是某些人所说的天真的消费行为。我认为这种习惯非常——我不知道“有益”是不是合适的词，但就像真的很开心、而且我不知道，没有什么威胁性——的一个方面是，收集这些小物件可以是一种真正美好的方式，去与你内心深处某种被你隐藏起来的部分建立联系，具体来说，你知道的，就是表达我们内心的孩童。这是一种重新找回年轻和童真的方式。在我们压力重重的成年生活中，有意识地重新与你内心那个感到天真、柔软和顽皮的部分建立联系，你知道的，这可能会无比强大，就像它可以成为一种极其强大的自我关怀行为，甚至是情绪调节的行为，让自己感到安全
and cared for by being the one who creates that kind of whimsical environment. And trinkets, you know, really play into that whimsical aesthetic. They might actually be very potent bridges to this connection between who you are now and some of the sensations and feelings that you had as a kid. Trinkets have an amazing ability to evoke childhood memories. You know, getting a jellycat, getting whatever it is, it might transport you back to the sheer excitement of getting a new toy as a kid or the thrill of collecting something that you really coveted or being spoiled.
and cared for by being the one who creates that kind of whimsical environment. And trinkets, you know, really play into that whimsical aesthetic. They might actually be very potent bridges to this connection between who you are now and some of the sensations and feelings that you had as a kid. Trinkets have an amazing ability to evoke childhood memories. You know, getting a jellycat, getting whatever it is, it might transport you back to the sheer excitement of getting a new toy as a kid or the thrill of collecting something that you really coveted or being spoiled.|||并通过成为那个创造这种奇幻环境的人来获得关爱。你知道的，小饰品非常契合这种奇幻的美学。它们实际上可能是连接你现在的身份与你小时候拥有的一些感觉和感受的非常强大的桥梁。小饰品具有唤起童年回忆的神奇能力。你知道的，买一个 Jellycat，或者买其他什么东西，它可能会把你带回小时候得到新玩具时的纯粹兴奋，或者收集你梦寐以求的东西或被溺爱时的那种狂喜。
It might also feel like you are able to give yourself something. you never received when you were younger. And we're not just talking about a physical toy, but love, comfort, again, someone's spoiling you. So this fulfillment, or I guess, re-experiencing of positive childhood emotions and also positive childhood emotions that come from something so simple and non-threatening as like a fluffy toy, it's deeply comforting and really affirming when everything else in life is very serious and very dangerous and very disheartedly.
It might also feel like you are able to give yourself something. you never received when you were younger. And we're not just talking about a physical toy, but love, comfort, again, someone's spoiling you. So this fulfillment, or I guess, re-experiencing of positive childhood emotions and also positive childhood emotions that come from something so simple and non-threatening as like a fluffy toy, it's deeply comforting and really affirming when everything else in life is very serious and very dangerous and very disheartedly.|||它也可能让你觉得你能够给自己一些你年轻时从未得到过的东西。我们谈论的不仅仅是一个实体玩具，还有爱、安慰，再次强调，有人在溺爱着你。因此，这种满足感，或者我猜，重新体验童年的积极情感，以及来自毛绒玩具这样简单且无威胁的事物的童年积极情感，当生活中其他一切都非常严肃、非常危险且非常令人心碎时，它是如此地令人深感慰藉和真正地予以肯定。
You know, this is a tangible connection and a link to a time that is often perceived is a lot simpler, a lot safer, and filled with a lot of like, you know, just unbridled joy. We can also kind of understand this connection through the lens of what psychologists call transitional objects. So this was a term coined in the 1950s by the British psychoanalyst Donald Winnicott. We talk about him a lot on the podcast, actually. And basically he, I don't think he discovered this, but he basically talked a lot about transitional objects, something like a security blanket or a teddy bear that served as a really crucial role in early childhood development as a way to help a child cope with separation from their primary caregiver.
You know, this is a tangible connection and a link to a time that is often perceived is a lot simpler, a lot safer, and filled with a lot of like, you know, just unbridled joy. We can also kind of understand this connection through the lens of what psychologists call transitional objects. So this was a term coined in the 1950s by the British psychoanalyst Donald Winnicott. We talk about him a lot on the podcast, actually. And basically he, I don't think he discovered this, but he basically talked a lot about transitional objects, something like a security blanket or a teddy bear that served as a really crucial role in early childhood development as a way to help a child cope with separation from their primary caregiver.|||你知道的，这是一种切实的联系，通往一个通常被认为简单得多、安全得多、并且充满了各种，你知道的，无拘无束的快乐的时代。我们也可以通过心理学家所称的“过渡对象（transitional objects）”的视角来理解这种联系。这是由英国精神分析学家唐纳德·温尼科特（Donald Winnicott）在 20 世纪 50 年代创造的一个词。实际上，我们在播客中经常谈论他。基本上他——我不认为这是他发现的——但他基本上大量谈论了过渡对象，比如安抚毛毯或泰迪熊，它们在幼儿早期发展中发挥着至关重要的作用，作为一种帮助孩子应对与主要抚养者分离的方式。
If you cast your mind way back to like your first day of kindergarten or your first day of school, you might remember that, you know, you probably brought a toy to class. That's something that a lot of early year teachers will recommend that like when children are first leaving their parents and spending a lot of time alone without them and their comfort to bring an object or a toy that reminds them of the comfort they experience, you know, from a caregiver. It's like this tangible thing that represents someone's presence or a particular emotion when the person who normally creates that emotion is absent. This is going to sound ridiculous, but there is evidence to support that adults still kind of want these comfort objects and they still want these transitional toys, basically.
If you cast your mind way back to like your first day of kindergarten or your first day of school, you might remember that, you know, you probably brought a toy to class. That's something that a lot of early year teachers will recommend that like when children are first leaving their parents and spending a lot of time alone without them and their comfort to bring an object or a toy that reminds them of the comfort they experience, you know, from a caregiver. It's like this tangible thing that represents someone's presence or a particular emotion when the person who normally creates that emotion is absent. This is going to sound ridiculous, but there is evidence to support that adults still kind of want these comfort objects and they still want these transitional toys, basically.|||如果你把思绪拉回到幼儿园的第一天或上学的第一天，你可能会记得，你知道的，你可能带了一个玩具去上课。这是许多幼儿老师会推荐的做法，比如当孩子们第一次离开父母，在没有父母和他们陪伴的情况下独自度过很长时间时，带一个物品或玩具，能让他们想起从抚养者那里体验到的安慰。它就像是一个实实在在的东西，当那个通常能创造这种情感的人不在场时，它代表着某个人的存在或特定的情感。这听起来可能很荒谬，但有证据表明，成年人基本上仍然有点想要这些安抚物品，他们仍然想要这些过渡玩具。
You know, certain trinkets can serve a similar psychological function or purpose. They become miniature security blankets or comfort items that help us really navigate the anxieties and complexities of adult life. I know this sounds bizarre, but they can actually offer a real sense of consistency and safety and familiarity when the rest of the world feels overwhelming. I, for one, it's going to sound strange, but anytime I get on a plane, I always bring one of my little cherub figurines, one of my sunny angels with me. Like whenever I travel, I always have one in my bag. Because I have such a, you know, fear of flying, it's, if I'm really, like, freaking out, it's kind of this weirdly anchoring force for me, which sounds ridiculous, but they just bring me so much joy. It's hard not to, like, feel okay
You know, certain trinkets can serve a similar psychological function or purpose. They become miniature security blankets or comfort items that help us really navigate the anxieties and complexities of adult life. I know this sounds bizarre, but they can actually offer a real sense of consistency and safety and familiarity when the rest_of the world feels overwhelming. I, for one, it's going to sound strange, but anytime I get on a plane, I always bring one of my little cherub figurines, one of my sunny angels with me. Like whenever I travel, I always have one in my bag. Because I have such a, you know, fear of flying, it's, if I'm really, like, freaking out, it's kind of this weirdly anchoring force for me, which sounds ridiculous, but they just bring me so much joy. It's hard not to, like, feel okay|||你知道的，某些小饰品可以起到类似的心理功能或目的。它们变成了微型安抚毛毯或安慰物品，帮助我们真正应对成年生活的焦虑和复杂性。我知道这听起来很诡异，但当世界上其他一切都让人感到不知所措时，它们确实能提供一种真实的一致性、安全感和熟悉感。就我个人而言——这听起来会很奇怪——每当我坐飞机时，我总是随身携带我的一个小天使手办，我的其中一个 Sonny Angel。就像我每次旅行时，我的包里总会有一个。因为我有很深的，你知道的，对飞行的恐惧，如果我真的，比如说，吓坏了，它对我来说就像是一种奇怪的锚定力量，听起来很荒谬，但它们确实给我带来了太多的快乐。很难不去觉得一切都还好
when I have one in my back. And also, there's this weird psychological sense of, like, oh, it can't be that bad. It can't be that scary if I have, like, a little naked baby in a costume in my pocket. That sounds really weird. If you don't know what these are, like just Google them and it will make sense. But yeah, it's just like, oh, how serious can this situation really be if I have this little figurine thing? It's like this weird thing to pull you out of a moment where you're getting too stressed. You know, also, Adol just demands a lot of seriousness and it demands a lot of responsibility.
when I have one in my back. And also, there's this weird psychological sense of, like, oh, it can't be that bad. It can't be that scary if I have, like, a little naked baby in a costume in my pocket. That sounds really weird. If you don't know what these are, like just Google them and it will make sense. But yeah, it's just like, oh, how serious can this situation really be if I have this little figurine thing? It's like this weird thing to pull you out of a moment where you're getting too stressed. You know, also, Adol just demands a lot of seriousness and it demands a lot of responsibility.|||当我的包里装着一个的时候。而且，还有一种奇怪的心理感觉，就像是：“哦，既然我的口袋里有一个穿着奇装异服的小光屁股娃娃，情况应该不会那么糟，也不会那么可怕吧。”这听起来真的很奇怪。如果你不知道这些是什么，去 Google 一下就明白了。但是，是的，这就像是：“哦，如果我身上有这个小玩偶，情况究竟能有多严肃呢？”这就像是一个奇怪的东西，能把你从压力过大的时刻中拉出来。你知道的，成年本身就需要极大的严肃性，也需要承担极大的责任。
And unfortunately, sometimes that comes with the suppression of spontaneous play and laughter and being silly and goofy and just stupid. And trinkets, by their very nature, are often non-functional. primary purpose is simply enjoyment and aesthetic pleasure and to be fun. I don't, I don't see the bad thing in that. I think that's something that actually a lot of adults could do with. I think it would really help us, I don't know, take things a little bit less seriously. It's probably the best way where I can put it. You know, engaging with them. I think it just really reintroduces a vital element of playful lightness into our adult lives. And here is when we finally arrived to
不幸的是，这有时会伴随着对自发玩耍、欢笑、傻气、滑稽以及单纯幼稚的压制。而且小饰品按其本质来说，通常是非功利性的。它们的主要目的纯粹是带来快乐、审美愉悦以及好玩。我不觉得这有什么不好的。我觉得成年人其实很需要这种东西。我觉得这真的能帮我们，怎么说呢，把事情看淡一点点。这大概是我能表达的最好方式了。你知道的，与它们互动。我觉得这真的为我们的成年生活重新注入了一种至关重要的、充满玩趣的轻盈感。而现在，我们终于聊到了
something that we've been kind of circling for most of this episode, which is incredibly important in this discussion, which is the power of nostalgia. The power of nostalgia is hard at work in really being the backbone of this industry. Collecting trinkets and small toys, like it's not a new concept. I think most of us used to have something that we collected as a child. For me, it was Beanie Babies. It was like literally. everything. Do you remember those pop figurines as well? Some people used to collect those, even if you collected stickers, like that everyone had something. And brands realize what an emotional pool it can be if they create something that reminds us of something from the past.
我们在这集的大部分时间里一直在兜圈子的话题，这个话题在这场讨论中极其重要，那就是怀旧的力量。怀旧的力量在发挥着重要作用，它确实成为了这个行业的顶梁柱。收集小饰品和小玩具，这并不是一个新概念。我想我们大多数人小时候都有过收集的东西。对我来说，是豆豆娃（Beanie Babies）。简直就是……一切。你还记得那些泡泡玛特（Pop Mart）手办吗？有些人以前会收集那些，甚至如果你收集贴纸，就像每个人都有自己收集的东西一样。各大品牌意识到，如果它们创造出能让人想起过去某些东西的产品，将会产生多么巨大的情感共鸣。
Because this thing from the past feels comforting. Let's like take Beanie Babies as an example, because I feel like everyone knows what a Beanie Baby is. Beanie Babies had this like very, unique bean-filled kind of texture and they had these quirky little names and they were incredibly cute and they were appealing. They were also kind of creepy and they were kind of like a medium-sized toy. I don't think it's crazy to say that there is a kind of a lot of similarities between jelly cats and beanie babies and also between things like Labooos and Beanie Babies and any number of soft blind box collectibles. Like it's very obvious to me that these brands are just being like, cool, if we can activate a similar feeling to one that people had in the
因为这种来自过去的事物能带来安慰。让我们以豆豆娃为例，因为我觉得每个人都知道什么是豆豆娃。豆豆娃有着非常独特的、填充了豆子的质感，它们有着古怪的小名字，极其可爱且极具吸引力。它们甚至有点诡异，而且它们是一种中等大小的玩具。我认为，说毛绒公仔（Jellycats）和豆豆娃之间有很大相似之处，以及拉布布（Labubus）和豆豆娃以及各种毛绒盲盒收藏品之间有相似之处，这并不疯狂。在我看来，非常明显的是，这些品牌只是在想：太好了，如果我们能唤起人们过去对收集可爱、毛茸茸的东西的类似感觉——这种感觉感觉相同，而且在某种奇怪的方面看起来也相同——我们就能赚一大笔钱。
past around collecting something cute and fluffy that feels the same and kind of looks the same in weird ways, we can make a heck ton of money. In essence, I think that a lot of these toys are like the beanie babies of the digital age. They are skillfully leveraging very similar psychological hooks like cuteness, scarcity, even like investment potential. But it's been amplified by this like the instant global reach and highly visual nature of modern social media. It's just history repeating itself, but with a much faster internet connection. And there's also this like perceived throwback to the good old days. Like these things are very grounding and they feel very familiar.
本质上，我认为很多这类玩具就像是数字时代的豆豆娃。它们巧妙地利用了非常相似的心理钩子，比如可爱度、稀缺性，甚至还有投资潜力。但它被现代社交媒体即时的全球覆盖范围和高度视觉化的本质放大了。这只是历史的重演，只是网速快得多罢了。而且这里面还有一种对美好旧时光的所谓怀念。这些东西非常具有落地感，让人感觉非常熟悉。
They have a very whimsical nature. It's really evoking like a bygone era. And these trinkets are careful. crafted to deliver that very warm, fuzzy emotional connection to our past. They're trying to provide psychological comfort, even if they're fresh off the production line. And ultimately, nostalgia transforms purchasing from, I guess, a purely functional or rational decision into a deeply emotional one. We reward ourselves with a nostalgic purchase because it puts us in a positive mood or it helps us preserve a very simple, nice feeling of connection to the past.
它们具有非常古怪奇特的特质。它真正唤起了一种逝去的时代感。而这些小饰品经过精心设计，能够在我们和过去之间建立起那种非常温暖、毛茸茸的情感连接。它们试图提供心理安慰，哪怕它们刚从生产线上下来。归根结底，怀旧将购买行为从一个纯粹功能性或理性的决定，转化为了一个深度情感化的决定。我们用一次怀旧的购买来犒赏自己，因为它能让我们保持积极的心态，或者它能帮我们保持一种与过去简单而美好的连接感。
All this stuff that we read about in textbooks when it comes to consumer decisions and the use of nostalgia and emotional hooks and even like decisions when it comes to the texture and the feel and the size of an object and all these things, like the cuteness of an object, all that stuff has been carefully crafted these days. Like there are studies on what kind of faces people think are more cute and what kind of textures or fabrics people find more comforting. And it's like they've taken all this information that we've known for a long time and all this psychology around what drives people to buy. And they've created like the perfect item, the perfect thing that we all want. Let's shift gears and let's really like I think it's time to talk about the economy.
所有这些我们在教科书里读到的关于消费决策、怀旧情绪和情感钩子的运用，甚至包括关于物体的质感、触感和尺寸的决策，以及所有这些东西，比如一个物体的可爱程度，所有这些如今都经过了精心设计。比如，有研究探讨人们认为什么样的脸更可爱，人们觉得什么样的质感或面料更具安慰感。这就好比他们吸收了我们长期以来掌握的所有这些信息，以及围绕是什么驱使人们购买的所有心理学知识。然后他们创造出了完美的商品，也就是我们大家梦寐以求的完美东西。让我们换个话题，我觉得现在是时候谈谈经济了。
I think it's time to really like I've been circling around it. it's time to talk about the money behind this. And whether or not something like Labibos are in fact a recession indicator. So this basically started as like a joke on TikTok and it has now spawned articles in the Australian Financial Review, in Vogue, in CNN, across countless blogs that the rise of collectibles and of collecting is a sign that the economy is about to freaking tank. If we really dive deeper into what's driving this recent surge in trinket culture, we can kind of develop a better understanding of why people and economists are like may be thinking this way. We know that the main proportion of these engaged consumers
我觉得是时候真正地——我之前一直在外围兜圈子——是时候谈谈这背后的金钱了。以及像拉布布（Labubus）这样的东西是否实际上是经济衰退的指标。所以这最初基本上只是TikTok上的一个玩笑，现在却在《澳大利亚金融评论报》、Vogue、《CNN》以及无数博客上催生了相关文章，指出收藏品和收集热潮的兴起，是经济即将彻底崩溃的迹象。如果我们深入探究是什么在推动近期这股小饰品文化的激增，我们就能更好地理解为什么人们和经济学家可能会有这种想法。我们知道，参与这些潮流的消费者的主力军
in these trends, primarily Gen Z and younger millennials, and this is the same generation that is facing very unique economic realities compared to their predecessors. I saw this really fascinating video from an amazing creator and a brand strategy consultant, I guess he is, on TikTok. His name is Eugene Healey. And he articulated this trend so perfectly. He basically discusses how, unlike previous generations, many young adults are finding themselves increasingly locked out of traditional markers of adult success, most notably home ownership.
主要是Z世代和年轻的千禧一代，而这正是面临着与前辈们截然不同的独特经济现实的一代人。我看到TikTok上一位了不起的创作者兼品牌战略顾问（我想他是干这个的）发布了一段非常迷人的视频。他完美地阐述了这一趋势。他基本上探讨了这样一个问题：与前几代人不同，许多年轻人发现自己越来越被排斥在传统的成年成功标志之外，其中最显著的就是拥有房产。
This is not new to us. I think everyone who is in their 20s understands this. These days, only around 23rd. 3% of people in their 20, so from 20 to 29 own home compared to 40% of boomers at the same age that we are. Like, everyone knows house prices outpacing wage growth. There's not enough houses. Mortgage rates are ridiculous.
这对于我们来说并不新鲜。我想每一个20多岁的人都对此心知肚明。如今，在20多岁（即20岁到29岁）的人群中，只有大约23.3%的人拥有自己的住房，而处于我们这个年龄的婴儿潮一代这一比例为40%。就像大家所知道的那样，房价涨幅远远超过了工资涨幅。房子根本不够。按揭利率高得离谱。
Whilst, you know, some people have found a way to enter the market, often with family assistance or by compromising on location or on significant parts of their life, most people, 77% of people in their 20s feel that home ownership is a very distant, if not impossible dream. So when big traditional aspirations like owning a home become unattainable, which I think is a sign that our economy isn't working if people literally can't afford shelter and the security of a home, where do people channel their desire for stability and personal expression and a sense of accomplishment into. Often, it's more accessible forms of consumption. Clothes, travel, cars, also trinkets.
虽然，你知道的，有些人已经找到了进入市场的方法，通常是借助家庭的帮助，或者通过在地理位置上妥协，或者在生活的重要部分做出妥协，但大多数人——77%的20多岁的人——觉得拥有房产是一个极其遥远、甚至是不可能的梦想。因此，当诸如拥有住房这样重大的传统宏伟志向变得无法实现时——我认为这正是我们经济运作失灵的标志，如果人们连栖身之所和家的安全感都买不起的话——人们会将对稳定、自我表达和成就感的渴望倾注到哪里去呢？通常，是更易获得的消费形式。衣服、旅游、汽车，还有小饰品。
Basically, you know, this generation, we may be locked out of the property market, but we feel very locked into this accessible delight of collecting. The idea that small, relatively inexpensive luxury items tend to surge during economic downturns is actually known as, you know, as the lipstick effect or lipstick economy theory. And it was popularized by someone called Leonard Lauder. Does that last name sound familiar? Lauder, i.e. Estée Lauder, one of the biggest beauty brands in the world. They own so many, like, smaller makeup companies.
基本上，你知道的，这一代人可能被房产市场拒之门槛之外，但我们深深沉迷于这种触手可及的收集乐趣中。这种认为小型、相对便宜的奢侈品往往在经济低迷时期激增的现象，实际上被称为“口红效应”或“口红经济理论”。它是由一个名叫伦纳德·劳德（Leonard Lauder）的人推广开来的。这个姓氏听起来耳熟吗？劳德，也就是雅诗兰黛（Estée Lauder），全球最大的美容品牌之一。他们旗下拥有众多较小的化妆品公司。
This guy, Leonard Lauder, the chairman of Estée Lauder, basically observed a spike in lipstick sales after the 9-11 terrorist attacks and also during the early 2000. recession. And he basically said when we are faced with economic uncertainty and tightening budgets and less money to spend overall on big things, we might go without larger, more significant purchases, but we still crave a sense of indulgence and a psychological pick-me-up. Lipstick, you know, that was the example he was working off of, is accessible and it's an affordable luxury and it's small. So it becomes the choice. form of indulgence when larger forms of indulgence are just out of reach. Just like that high-end
这家伙，雅诗兰黛的董事长伦纳德·劳德，基本上观察到了9·11恐怖袭击之后以及2000年代初经济衰退期间口红销量的飙升。他基本上说过，当我们面临经济不确定性、预算收紧以及用于大件商品的总体花销减少时，我们可能会放弃购买更大、更重要的物品，但我们仍然渴望得到一种纵容感和心理安慰剂。口红（你知道的，这就是他当时研究的例子）是触手可及的、负担得起的奢侈品，而且它很小。因此，当更大规模的放纵遥不可及的时候，它就成为了首选的放纵形式。就像那种高端的
lipstick, trinkets offer a little feeling of luxury and instant gratification without requiring the significant financial commitment of a big ticket item. And this perfectly aligns with what we know as little treat culture where consumers consciously opt for, you know, small, little frequent indulgences as a way to boost their mood, rather than larger splurges that are out of reach. You know, even in the midst of economic uncertainty and global uncertainty and maybe even a recession, we still want a sense of normalcy and we still want a sense of joy and happiness. And basically, that is what trinkets and Lububoos and jellycats and sunny angels and whatever else there is are a sign of. They are a sign of these companies coming to fill a gap in our
口红一样，小饰品提供了一种微小的奢华感和即时满足感，而无需承担购买大件商品所需的巨额财务承诺。这与我们所知的“小确幸文化”完美契合，在这种文化中，消费者有意识地选择频繁的小额放纵作为提升心情的方式，而不是去进行那些遥不可及的大肆挥霍。你知道的，即便身处经济的不确定性、全球的不确定性甚至可能是经济衰退之中，我们仍然渴望一种常态感，仍然渴望一种快乐和幸福感。基本上，这就是小饰品、拉布布、毛绒公仔、天使娃娃（Sonny Angels）以及其他种种东西所代表的信号。它们是这些企业前来填补我们经济缺口的信号。
economy. So with that bleak kind of picture in mind, we are going to take another short break. But when you return, we're going to talk about something a little bit different, which is the role of dopamine, the role of impulse buys, and whether we can call this behavior addictive. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs, when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
带着这种惨淡的画面，我们将进行另一个短暂的休息。但当你回来时，我们将讨论一个稍微不同的事情，那就是多巴胺的作用、冲动购买的作用，以及我们是否能将这种行为称之为成瘾。请继续收听。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个怪异的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真诚地认为种子油天然具有炎症性。
in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。认准在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（戏谑）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段日子的。包括最近的一期节目，马克·拉蒙特·hill（Mark Lamont Hill）滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊当年的可卡因，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks.
我开始看出这其中有一条主线了。我们现在甚至把艾滋病也摆上台面了。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要？
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth?
还是说你成为一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。确实如此。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地去做一个好人。加入我和卡尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。
Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
打开免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中极其明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战，只为证明真相。
Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试。我篡改测试是一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军才能破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士，迈克尔·莱皮安（Michael Lepian）、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Michael Lepian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。好了，我们回来了，我们要来聊聊小饰品。我认为，虽然收集小饰品非常有趣、充满欢乐，而且大多数时候也无伤大雅，但就其本身的构思和目前的这种设计方式而言，它们往往非常完美地迎合了冲动购买和过度消费。所以它们的价格相对较低，对吧？它们也非常非常可爱。而且如今它们都装在盲盒里。所以你并不知道自己会抽到什么。这有点像赌博，我们稍后会聊到这个。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, we are back and we are talking about trinkets. I think that whilst, you know, collecting trinkets is very fun and it's joyful and it's kind of harmless most of the time. By their very design and how they are being designed currently, they're often perfectly primed for impulse purchases and overconsumption. So they have this relatively low price point, right? They're also very, very cute. And these days, they're presented in blind boxes. So you don't really know what you're going to get. It's kind of like gambling, which we're going to talk about a little bit
但所有这些因素结合在一起，就会产生一种当场购买的即时冲动。与购买这些手办相关的即时多巴胺冲击，往往会凌驾于理性的财务未来规划之上。如果不谨慎行事，它可能会导致一种非常习惯性的、频繁的过度消费，而所买的东西——尽管它很可爱——其实并不是我们真正需要的。我也认为，如今网购的极度便利以及一键购买，实际上进一步消除了可能让我们进行“三思”以及“我真的需要这个吗？”的摩擦力。社交媒体在这种类似竞争性的
later. But all of these things combine and create this immediate urge to buy on the spot. The instant kind of dopamine hit associated with buying these figures often overrides rational financial future planning. If not done cautiously, it can lead to a very habitual and frequent overspending over something that, you know, as much as it's cute, we don't really need. I also think that the sheer ease of online shopping these days and one-click purchasing effectively even further removes the friction that might otherwise allow for kind of like a second thought and a second thought of like, do I need this? Social media also has a really critical role to play in this kind of like competitive
消费主义中也扮演着至关重要的角色。看到那些完美策划的收藏品、稀有的战利品、海量的开箱分享，或者你所崇拜的人在网上拥有这些东西，往往会产生一种强烈的压力，逼迫你去获取更多，去拥有最好的收藏，或者仅仅是为了跟上其他人的步伐。而这非常悲哀地会将人们推向远超自身经济能力的消费，这是由社会比较而非真实渴望所驱动的。由于这种比较，以及害怕错过最新最棒、能证明你紧跟潮流的物品，人们对能否成功买到这件物品产生情感投入也就不足为奇了。这不仅仅是关于拥有尽可能多的数量，
consumerism. Seeing perfectly curated collections, rare finds, massive holes, people who you admire, online having this thing often creates intense pressure to acquire more, to have the best collection, or simply to kind of just like keep pace with other people. And this can really tragically push people to spend well above their means and it's driven by social comparison more than genuine desire. Because of this comparison and a fear of missing out on the latest and greatest item that shows that you're in the no, it's really not a surprise that people get emotionally invested in whether they manage to actually get the item. It's not just about having as many as possible,
而是关于只要拥有一两个就能证明你是这个群体中的一员。这会导致更多的冲动消费，比如一些你没有预算、没有考虑进去的东西，你不得不不断购买最新流行趋势的物品，只为了让自己觉得融入其中。而你可能只是再次顺从这种冲动，因为你不想错过。而在幕后，这被称为饥饿营销，它几乎对我们所有人都起到了超额的作用。你有没有发现，当某样东西流行起来时，就很难买到？想想比如The Ordinary的润唇膏（Rhode lipsticks），想想拉布布，想想任何流行产品。总有一段时间你是买不到那个东西的。这不是偶然。绝不是。
it's about just having one or two to show that you're part of the group. This can lead to even more impulse spending, like something that you didn't budget for, something that you didn't account for, that you have to constantly buy the new trending item to feel like you fit in. And you might simply follow this urge again because you don't want to miss out. Behind the scenes, as well, this is called scarcity marketing, and it is working overtime on nearly all of us. Have you noticed that when something is trending, it's a lot harder to get? Think like the road lipsticks, think the luboos, think any number of trending products. There is a period where you cannot get your hands on that thing. That is not by accident. It's not. It's not.
绝不是因为这些公司不知道人们会有多么渴望他们的产品。这是因为当他们首次推出某样东西时，他们将其营造得很稀缺，从而让人产生更强烈的渴望，这创造了巨大的未来需求，并在你拥有这个可能原本不存在的机会时，产生了一种无时无刻的紧迫感——买、买、买。你们可能真的不知道的一件事是，我其实拥有经济学学位。我就顺便提一下，我在大学里主修心理学的同时也辅修了经济学。这是他们在微观经济学入门里教你的一个非常基础的原理，基本上就是当需求大于供给时，人们会为某样东西支付更多的钱。因此，当你刻意减少或限制供给时，
not because these companies didn't know how much people would want their product. It's because when they first launch something, they make it so that it is scarce so that people want it more, which creates huge future demand and an ever-present sense of urgency to buy, buy, buy when you got the opportunity that may have otherwise not been there. Something you guys may actually not know is that I actually have an economics degree. I'm just going to throw that out there, but I studied economics at uni alongside studying psychology. And this is a really basic principle that they teach you in like microeconomics 101, which is basically that when the demand is more than the supply, people will pay more for something. And so when you deliberately reduce or limit supply,
这是一种控制价格、控制市场以及控制消费者行为的方法。用最简单的方式来想，想想当地杂货店里的橙子价格与岛上的橙子价格之间的区别。在你当地的杂货店，他们必须把橙子或牛奶的价格定在接近市场价的水平，因为如果不这样做，你可以去另一家杂货店，能以更便宜的价格买到它。但是，举个例子，当你在一个岛上，橙子较少，你可以去买这种东西的地方也不多时，你就会心甘情愿地为这个东西支付更多的钱。你会支付更多，首先是因为没有其他地方可以买到它，其次是因为你看到这个物品更加稀缺，你认为它更有价值。因此，基本上现在很多公司都在利用这种货源短缺
it is a way to control prices and to control the market and to control consumer behavior. In the most simplest way, think about the cost of oranges on, you know, at your local grocery store versus on an island. So at your local grocery store, they have to charge somewhere near the market price for an orange or for milk, because if they don't, you can go to another grocery store and you'll find it for cheaper. But when, for example, you're on an island and there's less oranges and there's not as many places that you can go to get an item, you will easily pay more for that thing. You'll pay more because, firstly, there's not other places that you can get it, but also because you see that item is more scarce and you see it as more valuable. So basically, a lot of companies these days are taking that lack of availability
以及商品的独家性，来进一步激发人们对其所制造产品的强烈渴望。所以基本上，他们刻意制造诸如限量系列或超稀有物品，或者刻意只进行限量发售，这样当时机成熟时，他们不仅可以以远超其价值的价格出售它们，而且他们也知道永远都会有人排队等着买单。这也是为什么每当，比如说，一个新的系列发售或者某样东西突然有货时，人们就会开始囤货。我前几天看到一个视频，（不管怎样）比如某个泡泡玛特的自动售货机，最前面的某个家伙把货全买光了，买了大约20个——没有人需要20个。你不需要
and the exclusivity of their items and using that to drive an even higher desire to own something that they make. So basically they're deliberately creating things like limited collections or super rare items or deliberately only doing limited drops so that when the time comes, they can not only sell them for a much higher price than what they're worth, but they also know they will always have people in line waiting to buy them. It's also why when, for example, a new collection drops or when something suddenly becomes available, people start hoarding. I saw this video the other day of, you know, whatever, like a pop-mart vending machine and some guy at the very front buying out, buying like 20, no one needs 20. You don't
20个。这太荒谬了。就像是，搞什么？但因为你知道你可以转售它们，因为它们的感知价值更高，他们知道人们不会只买一个就满足，他们会买很多个，因为需求大于供给。所以这种买更多的冲动，对吧？它看起来非常非常强烈，特别是对于收藏品而言。听着，这就是全部的意义所在。它们是你收集的东西，你会获得更多。正因为如此，我们能把这种习惯称之为成瘾吗？
need 20. Like, that's ridiculous. It's like, what? But because you know that you can resell them, because the perceived value of them is higher, they know that someone isn't just going to buy one and be satisfied, they're going to buy a lot of them because the demand is higher than the supply. So this drive to buy more, right? It seems very, very powerful, especially with collectibles. Like, that's the whole point. They are something you collect, you gain more of them. Because of that, could we call this habit addictive?
这是一个复杂的问题，但简短的回答是：是的，某些方面绝对可以，特别是盲盒以及对稀有物品的执着追求，绝对能够触及既有的成瘾心理机制。你可能会对获得这种东西的途径上瘾，或者对购买更多、更多的盲盒、更多的小饰品上瘾，恨不得把你能弄到手的所有东西都收入囊中。这核心在于我们大脑的多巴胺和奖励系统。我们知道多巴胺是一种非常强大的神经递质。当我们经历令人愉悦、兴奋、有回报的事情，或者经历我们一直在期待的事情时，它就会释放出来。这就是经济学家所说的“多巴胺经济”。在小饰品的语境下，这种多巴胺的爆发发生在几个
It's a complex question, but the short answer is yes, certain aspects, particularly with blind boxes and the relentless pursuit of rare items can absolutely tap into established addictive psychological mechanisms. You can become addicted to gaining access to this thing or buying more, more of more blind boxes, more trinket items, having as many as you possibly can get your hands on. At the heart of it lies our brain's dopamine and reward systems. Dopamine, we know that it's a very powerful neurotransmitter. It is released when we experience something pleasurable, exciting or rewarding or something that we have been anticipating. This is what economists actually call the dopamine economy. And in the context of trinkets, this dopamine rush occurs at several
关键时刻。它发生在你要拿到某样东西之前，你在心里琢磨：我能抽到一个吗？还是抽不到？这就有了期待感。它发生在你完成购买并拥有它的时候。它发生在开箱的时候。它发生在也许你找到了一个稀有物品的时候。它发生在集齐一套的时候，它发生在你回头买更多的时候。这种多巴胺的激增强有力地强化了这种行为，你的大脑会迅速了解到“购买或开箱这个动作等于快乐”，从而产生一种强烈而根深蒂固的渴望，驱使你不断重复这一行为。这就是我们所谓的“操作性条件反射”的核心。伴随着令人满意的结果的行为更有可能被重复。这就把我们引向了第二个迷人的问题。
key moments. It occurs before you get your hands on something and you're questioning, am I going to get one? Am I not? There's anticipation. It occurs when you make the purchase and you have it. It occurs when you open the box. It occurs when you find maybe a rare item. It occurs when you complete a set, it occurs when you go back for more. This surge of dopamine powerfully reinforces the behavior and your brain quickly learns that this action of buying or unboxing equals pleasure, leading to a strong ingrained desire to continue to repeat that action. This is the core of what we call operant conditioning. Behaviors followed by a satisfying consequence are more likely to be repeated. So this leads us to kind of a second fascinating question.
盲盒不仅会让人上瘾，它们是不是根本就是另一种形式的赌博？这就是为什么我们对它们如此痴迷的原因吗？盲盒与“波吉机”（pokies，指老虎机）或老虎机赌博或你可能想到的任何其他形式的赌博之间，绝对存在相似之处，特别是在推动参与度的底层机制方面，也就是“间歇性强化”的概念。让我来解释一下这一点。基本上，在经典的赌博中，你永远不知道你的下一注会不会赢，
Not only are blind boxes addictive, but are they simply just another form of gambling? Is that why we get so hooked on them? There are absolutely parallels between blind boxes and the pokies or slot gambling or whatever kind of gambling you may be thinking of, especially concerning the underlying mechanisms that drive engagement, which is the idea of intermittent reinforcement. So let me explain this. Basically, in classic gambling, you never know if your next bet is going to win,
但派彩的可能性让你不断玩下去。而在盲盒中，你不知道自己会抽到哪一个特定的手办，但获得稀有物品或极受追捧的物品的可能性让你不断购买它们。这一基本原理创造了一个高度持久且引人入胜的行为循环。不确定性和期待感是赌博和盲盒的核心。就像打开盲盒时的惊险期待，非常类似于你在拉动老虎机手柄之前的期待。它会产生即时的兴奋感、期待感和多巴胺的涌动。未知的结局正是
but the possibility of a payout keeps you playing. In blind boxes, you don't know which specific figure you're going to get, but the possibility of obtaining a rare one or a highly desired item keeps you buying them. This fundamental principle creates a highly persistent and compelling behavioral loop. The element of uncertainty and the anticipation is central to both, gambling and blind boxes. Like the thrilling anticipation of opening a blind box is much like the anticipation you have before pulling the leather on a slot machine. It generates immediate excitement, anticipation and a rush of dopamine. The unknown outcome is precisely what is
让这种体验如此迷人的原因所在。其中还包含着固有的财务风险。当然，与传统赌博相比，盲盒的规模肯定要小一些，但你永远说不准。你是在为未知的结局花钱。我记得我曾试图向我妈解释这一点，她的反应是：“什么叫你不知道自己会抽到哪个？”她说：“这太荒谬了。想象一下去看电影，却不知道自己买的是哪部电影的票，只是祈祷它是你想看的那部。”她说：“没有哪个行业是那样运作的。”我向她描述的方式是：“是的，你最后得到的可能并不是你特别想要的东西，但你也可能得到非常棒、非常让人渴望的东西。”
making this experience so alluring. There's also the inherent financial risk involved. I'll be it, you know, it's definitely on a smaller scale with blind boxes than traditional gambling, but you never know. You are spending money for an uncertain outcome. I remember trying to explain this to my mom and she was like, what do you mean you don't know which one you get? She's like, that's ridiculous. Imagine going to a movie and not knowing what movie you were going to get tickets to and just hoping it was the one that you wanted to go to. She's like, no other industry works that way. The way I described it to her was like, yes, you could end up with something that you don't particularly want, but you could also end up with something really good and really desisting.
而且你最后得到的可能是一个价值不菲的东西，你可以把它转售出去，然后你就可以买更多，这就是整个循环。你知道的，抽到多个废品或重复手办的挫败感，在赌博中也有一个术语。它被称为“追逐损失”，即不断购买更多的盒子，或者不断地进行赌博，抱着你终于能赢一次的心态。问题在于，实际上你可能会认为这些损失会让人（你知道的）重新定向并告诉他们收手。但你陷得越深，你陷进老虎机越深，你陷进盲盒越深，你就越绝对需要赢一次，因为否则你所有的钱都白白打水漂了。所以它并不是显式地
desirable. And you could also end up with one that is worth a lot of money and you can resell it and then you can buy more and it's this whole cycle. The frustration you know of getting multiple duds or duplicate figures as well, that also has a gambling term. It's called chasing losses, continuously buying more boxes or continuously gambling with the hope that you're finally going to win. The thing is, is that actually you would think that these losses told, you know, kind of redirected someone and told them to stop. But the more you sink into something, the more you sink into the slot machines, the more you sink into the blind boxes, the more you then definitely need a win, because otherwise you've lost all that money for nothing. So it's not explicitly
赌博，但也有一些争论认为，像盲盒这样的东西确实在很小的年龄就向年轻人（尤其是年轻人）引入了这些类似赌博的机制。因此，如果你是一个家长，或者如果你是一个消费者，可能你并不知道这一点，只是觉得：“噢，这只是一个无害的玩具。这只是一个毛茸茸的可爱的宝贝。我给我的孩子们一些钱，然后我再给他们一些钱，接着突然之间他们就需要更多的钱了。”你可能没有意识到，实际上在幕后发生的心态调理，其根源同样在于间歇性强化，根源于制造赌博成瘾者的相同机制。这可能会有可能使未来的、赌注高得多的赌博行为趋于正常化，甚至为之做好铺垫。
gambling, but there have been some arguments that things like blind boxes do actually introduce young people in particular to these gambling like mechanisms at a really early age. So if you're a parent or if you're a consumer, like, you might not know this and you're just like, oh, it's a harmless toy. It's just like this cute little fluffy thing. I'll give my kids some money and then I'll give them some more money and then suddenly they need more money. You might not realize that actually the psychological conditioning that is happening behind the scenes is rooted in, again, intermittent reinforcement, rooted in the same mechanisms that create gambling addicts. And that could have the potential to normalize or even prime individuals for future gambling behaviors where
发展心理学的研究凸显了儿童和青少年对这类强化时间表的敏感度，这意味着他们更容易受到这种条件反射的影响。2021年在澳大利亚新南威尔士州（我居住的州）进行的一项研究实际上发现，至少在短期内，那些购买或出售在线“战利品箱”（loop boxes）或盲盒的年轻女孩和青春期女孩，实际上对赌博表现出了更积极的态度。与那些没有表现出这些早期行为或没有参与这些早期买卖交易行为的人相比，她们更有可能想要在赌注更高的环境中进行赌博。这恰恰说明了年轻人对这些东西是多么容易受到影响，以及我们在鼓励这种不确定的购买行为时，可能需要额外提高警惕。
the stakes are much higher. Research and developmental psychology highlights how sensitive children and teenagers are to these kinds of reinforcement schedules, and it means that they are more vulnerable to such conditioning. There was a 2021 study conducted here in Australia in New South Wales, the state I live in, that actually found that at least in the short term, young girls and adolescent girls who bought or sold online kind of loop boxes or blind boxes actually demonstrated more positive attitudes towards gambling. They were more likely to want to gamble in a more high-stakes setting compared to those who didn't behave in these early or didn't engage in these early kind of trade-sell behaviors. And it just shows how malleable young people are to these things
进行这样的对话非常重要。说出这样的话非常重要，你知道的，归根结底，这个行业不仅仅是为了让你开心。人们制造盲盒并不是——像泡泡玛特和所有这些公司制造这些并不是因为他们只希望你玩得开心。他们制造这些并刻意这样做，是因为他们知道，如果他们利用这些心理洞察，就能赚到巨额财富。正如社交媒体被设计成会让人上瘾一样，社交媒体平台上也有真正的神经科学家团队来让你欲罢不能。这些公司同样拥有
and the extra layer of caution we might need when encouraging this kind of uncertain buying behavior. And it's really important to have this conversation. It's really important to say, you know, this industry is at the end of the day, not just based on making you happy. Like people aren't creating buying boxes like Pop Mart and all these companies aren't creating this because they just want you to have fun. They're creating this and they're doing this deliberately because they know that they can make a crap ton of money if they leverage these psychological insights. The same way that social media has been designed to be addictive and social media platforms have literal neuroscientists on their team to keep you hooked. These companies have
神经科学家团队来让你持续购买。所以在对话中加入这一点非常重要。同样重要的是要明白，将收集和小饰品作为一种爱好，并不总是充满危险的。有很多方式
neuroscientists on their team to keep you buying. So it's just important to add that into the conversation. It's also important as well to understand that collecting and trinkets as a hobby, it's not all the time always going to be dangerous. There are many ways. ways that it can play out that is just really enjoyable and completely harmless. So I don't want to like completely pathologize and scorn this hobby. This is a hobby that I have and I don't particularly think that I'm addicted. And for me, it's always been a source of joy. Millions upon millions of people worldwide collect various items. They collect stamps. They collect coins. They collect action figures. They collect art, designer toys, whatever it is. And a lot of them, the majority of
可以让它以一种真正令人愉快且完全无害的方式进行。所以我不想把这个爱好完全病理化和贬低。这也是我的一个爱好，而且我不认为自己特别上瘾。对我来说，它一直是快乐的源泉。全球有成百上千万的人收集各种各样的东西。他们收集邮票。他们收集硬币。他们收集手办、艺术品、设计师玩具，无论是什么。他们中的很多人、绝大多数人
them don't develop a problematic addiction and they don't spend more than their means. So for most of us, this activity is just a genuine source of pleasure. It's a creative outlet. It's a means of social expression, personal expression. It's just a fulfilling harmless hobby. And I think that finishing on that context is important because the pursuit of joy, which is what this is really all about, is definitely a fundamental human need. if a small, well-considered purchase of a trinket genuinely brings a smile to your face, genuinely makes you feel joyful and happy and childlike and peaceful, there's immense value in that. You know, we are not robots designed solely for productivity and efficiency.
并没有发展出成瘾的问题，也没有超支消费。所以对我们大多数人来说，这项活动只是纯粹的快乐之源。它是一个创意的出口。它是社交表达、个人表达的一种手段。它只是一个充实且无害的爱好。我觉得以这样的背景来收尾是很重要的，因为追求快乐——这才是这一切的真正意义所在——绝对是人类的基本需求。如果一次微小、经过深思熟虑的小饰品购买确实能让你脸上露出微笑，确实让你感到快乐、幸福、童真和平静，那里面就蕴含着巨大的价值。你知道的，我们不是专门为了生产力和效率而设计的机器人。
Like, our emotional well-being is critical and it's an irreplaceable component of a truly fulfilling life. So if this thing brings you joy, sometimes it might not be worth examining it any time. deeper than that. Sometimes it's okay to just engage in it and not feel shame and not feel like you're being manipulated. It is still just a real simple, the simple like pathway to happiness. And yes, some people would argue that buying happiness or having to buy things to make you happy is inherently wrong or bad, but it is also just kind of the world that we live in. Everything costs money these days. As long as you are being healthy about it and that you're you're also seeking out happiness and purpose and fulfillment beyond just financial transactions
就像我们的情感健康至关重要一样，它是真正充实生活中不可替代的组成部分。所以如果这个东西能给你带来快乐，有时也许不值得去深入探究。有时候，去享受它、不感到羞耻、不觉得自己被操纵，也是可以的。这依然是一条通往幸福的真实而简单的途径。是的，有些人可能会认为购买快乐，或者必须买东西才能让自己快乐，这本质上是错误或不好的，但这某种程度上也是我们生活的世界。如今什么都要花钱。只要你对它抱持健康的态度，并且除了金钱交易
and the act of buying something. I think you're, I think you're okay. I think that trinket collecting is not, it's not the devil for you and is not a huge, terrible evil. Like, I do it. I, I know that perhaps there are systems at play that have gotten me into this, but I also know that I've been doing this since I was a kid. And I also know I've been doing it with things that I just collected out in nature, like rocks and flowers and, you know, insects back when I was a kid. So I know this is kind of part of who I am. And so, yeah, I don't necessarily feel terrible about it. And I don't think you should either. Just be conscious of the industry. Just be conscious of the space that this exists in. And I'm going to say like the most corny thing, but make smart decisions and you'll be all right.
和购买行为本身之外，你也在寻求快乐、目标和成就感，我觉得你就没问题。我觉得小饰品收集并不是你的恶魔，也不是什么巨大的、可怕的邪恶事物。你看，我也在做这事。我清楚，也许有某些机制在发挥作用把我拉进了这个坑，但我也知道我从小时候就开始这么做了。我也知道我以前用在自然界中随手收集的东西做过这事，比如我小时候收集的石头、花朵和昆虫。所以我知道这是我骨子里的一部分。所以，是的，我对它并没有感到特别糟糕。你也不应该有这种感觉。只需要对这个行业保持清醒的认识。只需要对它所存在的空间保持清醒的认识。我要说一句最老套的话，但做出明智的决定，你就会没事的。
hope that you really enjoyed this episode. I hope that you learned a lot. I hope that it's caused you to think and have interesting conversations with your friends. Maybe you can send this to a friend who themselves has a real fascination with trinket collecting, has a big sunny angel collection, has been really leaning into the Lubbubu trend. Hopefully they enjoy it as much as you do. Leave a comment down below if you collect something. I want to know what people collect. Even if it was something that you collected as a child just to see how far this habit and this behavior goes. I think it's so endlessly fascinating. Also make sure that you are following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast.
希望你们真的很喜欢这一期节目。希望你们学到了很多。希望它引发了你们的思考，并让你们和朋友们展开了有趣的对话。也许你可以把它分享给某个对收集小饰品有着真正狂热、拥有庞大天使娃娃（Sonny Angels）收藏、一直深深陷入拉布布（Labubus）潮流的朋友。希望他们能像你一样喜欢它。如果你有收集什么东西，请在下方留言。我想知道大家都收集些什么。哪怕是你小时候收集的东西也行，只是为了看看这种习惯和行为到底有多深远。我觉得这真的是无休止地迷人。同时也确保在Instagram上关注我，账号是That Psychology Podcast。
And follow along here as well. If you're listening on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, make sure you are subscribed so that you know when new episodes are being released and leave us a five-star review if you feel cool to do so. But with that in mind, thank you again for joining us. Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Enjoy a small trinket every now and again. and we will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all?
请也关注我们。如果您是在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上收听，请务必订阅，以便了解新集数的发布时间，如果您觉得不错，请给我们留下五星好评。话虽如此，再次感谢您的加入。注意安全，保持善良，对自我温柔一点。偶尔享受一下小饰品，我们很快就会再次交流。嘿，大家好吗？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Care Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
您正在收听的是由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Care Games为您带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但您是在与一位知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the eye, radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你就需要这样做，请在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《learn the hard way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mianini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Tram. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉利斯皮和迈克尔·米安尼尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Tram》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会从另一端走出来
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是数字2%。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝，在IHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是由人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。